Today we're going to talk about Ireland
and England, predominantly England.
It's not because Ireland isn't important,
but because we know less about Ireland,
the reason we know relatively more
about England in its post Roman period,
that is to say after, um, uh,
four 20 is uh,
because of the historian bead
writing in the early 18th century,
a monk at a gyro which was a part
of a twin monastery in North Umbria,
can see on your map the northeastern
port part of England before you get to
what's now Scotland Bead
wrote among other things,
a history of the English church and
people which is full of miracles and very,
very here, no pro Christian
as much as Gregory of tour,
but is a much more um,
easy to follow narrative and a
narrative with a certain kind of point.
It's about the conversion of England
and the establishment of the church.
The other advantage for
England over Ireland in terms
of evidence is archeology.
A lot more has been done
with excavating sites in, um,
England and by England we
mean literally England.
The part that is not whales,
not Scotland, uh, not Ireland.
The part of the British Isles,
the ensemble,
essentially the two islands are
referred to as the British eyes.
Britain is England,
Scotland and Wales.
Ireland is Ireland. Uh,
the Britains, however, B r,
I t o n s are the collective
term for the Celtic population.
Celtic is both a linguistic group
and a somewhat vague ethnic term.
It means the people who were there in
the British isles before the Romans came
and who were there afterwards
fighting invaders from Europe.
These invaders who come in the four
forties, known as the Anglo Saxons.
Bead tells us it's the Anglo Saxon.
The Saxons excusing the angles,
the Saxons and the jutes.
The angles give their name
to England angle land.
The jutes we know nothing
about. So, you know,
certain kind of medievalist uh,
we'll go on about founding a
journal of Jute Studies, uh,
and inviting contributors to something
that we really have absolutely no idea.
It would be, you know, in that League
of smallest, thinnest Vanya items. Um,
at least in terms of three
dimensional box, uh, the Saxons,
uh, come from, there is still a very
large part of Germany called Saxony.
Uh,
what the nature of these peoples are,
how they were differentiated
among themselves is a
source of a lot of Rio or at
least looks real scholarship as
opposed to studying the glutes.
But we don't have to go into that,
can need to get the cast of characters,
Celts angle Anglo Saxons
and the Anglo Saxons
conquer much of the island,
more or less what would become England.
But not all.
They do not conquer Scotland.
They do not conquer whales and
they don't really conquer cornball.
So the western part of
Britain remains Celtic.
And to this day,
whales and Scotland considered themselves
different from England can get into a
lot of trouble by calling that,
uh,
area England with the people there.
And um,
particularly in Scotland
there's a possibility that
they may separate from the
United Kingdom at some point.
Ireland Ireland was never
occupied by the Romans.
Ireland, um, was,
caltech was in contact
with the Roman Empire
but was not part of it.
This makes some difference and we'll
talk about it when we come to talk about
conversion,
but it doesn't make as much difference
as it sounds because the thing about
England or Britain is that the Roman
impressed there would be almost wiped out
once the Romans withdrew.
And so in contrast to what we saw with
Gregory of tour and Merovingian Gall
Merovingian, uh, Frankish kingdom,
the Roman influence in
Britain is almost wiped out.
Recall what we saw as persistence of
Roman practices in the mirror of kingdom
bishops,
cities,
the Latin language
tax records,
written legal codes.
That is not to say that the mirror
of engines weren't, as I said before,
to be described by technical terms
like thugs or that this was a sleek,
well-functioning kingdom. You know,
you landed at the airport and, uh,
you know,
got the train immediately and everything
was sleek and nice like Amsterdam or
some place like that as
opposed to Kennedy. But, uh,
that,
um,
the Roman inheritance was visible and
influential in Britain when the Roman
troops withdrew to fight, uh, the, um,
uh,
invaders in Gaul,
this ended Roman society and Britain.
And the reason for this is partly the
Britain was a frontier viewed from the
point of view of the Mediterranean,
the center of gravity of the Roman empire.
The
frontier symbolized bumps
dramatically by walls,
the most famous of
which is Hadrian's wall,
a wall that separated out the barbarians.
But since you didn't have a river
like the Daniel Board, the Rhine,
there seems to be no natural frontier.
Remanence of Hadrian's
wall are the largest,
um,
souvenir of the Roman era.
A wall to keep out the barbarians
from the north because in fact,
the Romans didn't conquer
the entire island.
They conquered the parts they thought
were worthwhile and they did think it was
worthwhile frontier or not.
We know that the Romans built
villas might be a little cold,
the somewhat open Air Mediterranean
plan things, but, uh, you know,
mosaic court yards, uh,
drank a lot of wine,
but to have it imported, uh, built cities,
walls,
other fortifications,
cultivated land.
So it's not as if there wasn't a Roman
serious Roman province of Britain from
its conquest in the late first century
until it's abandonment in the early fifth
century.
But here the invaders tended to obliterate
much of what had been there in Roman
times and the Celtic population
who had been romanized,
at least at the elite levels.
The Celtic population didn't really
save very much from the Roman empire.
The Celts, uh, might remain Christian,
whereas the invaders were pagan.
But the Celts tended not to have
cities or at least large centers
and they tended not to have or
retain Roman forms of government.
The one kind of,
if not literally interesting,
at least weird aspect of Celtic Roman
resistance is the figure of King Arthur.
I'm going to bring them up now
and then I'm going to drop him.
King Arthur belongs properly to the
continuation of this course because his,
uh,
legendary status starts in the
really in the world of romance,
of French Romance and then of
Romance Chevelle Rick Literature.
By romance we mean not, it not only
loves stories but novels of Chivalry,
of nights of battles.
He is a figure who is 99.9% legend.
Uh,
whatever the remainder of that 0.1% real.
And so far as he's real,
he may be identified with Celtic
resistance to the Anglo Saxon invaders,
Celtic Roman resistance in the late fifth,
early sixth centuries.
But the proportion of art to
history in this is if not 99.9,
at least. Very, very substantial.
So the original setting of the Arthurian
stories is that of the resistance to
the Anglo Saxon invaders. The, uh,
Arthurian romances do have
a kind of Celtic begin,
well not a kind of,
they have a Celtic beginning and then
they are our appropriated by people in the
romance language tradition French,
first of all.
So as what comes says on page one 51,
nowhere else in the Roman empire
was the collapse of culture,
economy and urbanization.
So complete.
He uses that wonderful phrase again.
Uh,
radical economic simplification.
I,
he, uh, you know, there's no
more plumbing. There was no more,
uh, there's no more sort of a what
we would consider to be affluent,
civilized society. The ceramics
don't come from Africa anymore.
The wine doesn't come from France
anymore. People are uh, um,
reduced to a kind of subsistence or at
least most people because as we'll see,
some of these kings actually
are able to get, uh,
some luxury goods from abroad.
If it were just a story
of Barbara's aviation,
it would be less interesting then in fact,
the peculiar nature of
England in this period,
which goes from being a
contested territory between
the Germanic invaders and
the Celtic population to a kingdom slowly
converted in the course of the seventh
century to Christianity from paganism
to the leading center of Culture in
Europe feed who lived from six 73 to seven
35 was the most cultivated scholar in
Europe of the early eighth century.
And the most cultivated scholar in Europe
of the late 18th century was also from
England,
uh,
eloquent counselor and
advisor to Charlemagne.
How do you go from being a,
uh,
well,
I don't like to use the word primitive,
but certainly barbarian enough area
to having the largest libraries,
the, uh, most cultivated a scholars now.
It is true.
As I think I've said before,
that any time you can say that such and
such a person was the smartest person in
Europe has got to be a fairly bad time,
right?
In the 19th century,
you have your choice from all
sorts of scientific literary,
uh, um, other kinds of intellectual
experts who, who, you know,
who would even dare to say, but, um,
you know,
we know that,
but we theists and Casio doors are the
smartest guys in Europe in the sixth
century because have access to stuff
that almost no one else does because
they're writing about a classical authors
that almost no one else has in their
libraries.
And we know that Isidore of Seville is
probably the smartest guy of the early
seventh century. And visit Gothic
Spain, um, because we have his works,
we have an idea of what he's read,
we know his sources. And again,
he's got the biggest library.
Biggest library may mean a hundred books,
but a hundred books in 780 is a
serious collection of knowledge.
Now, this is not easy knowledge.
This is not, you know,
as if everything were,
um,
uh, well I don't want to
say Wikipedia either. Uh,
everything, we're kind of like
Wikipedia five years ago, um,
elementary and often wrong.
These aren't very different kinds of
works from what might interest us.
Certainly a lot of biblical
stuff, but also, for example,
a lot of computing of time
bead would be remembered for the history
of the English church and people,
but also for a lot of his
works on figuring out time.
He is credited,
although not uniquely credited,
but is an important person
in the development of the BC,
a d scheme.
Believe it or not,
people are not born into the world
calculating according to BC a day,
lots of people calculate
according to other systems.
How did they come up with this?
And Moreover,
how do they then fit the calendar into it?
How do you keep time when you don't have
electric or battery operated clocks?
How do you know what the seasonal changes?
Okay.
But in fact,
that most troublesome problem,
which had been particularly controversial
to the conversion of England in the
generation before bead in the early
seventh and mid seventh century was the
calculation of Easter.
Easter is a real problem.
Now, naturally, it's not a
problem if someone else tells you,
if you know,
in 1970 you open up a little
pocket book calendar and you know,
it says, okay, Easter is
this day. You trust them.
Or now,
you know,
if you have some feature on your iPhone
that gives you Easter for the next 3000
years in case you want to know
when Easter is in, uh, you know,
3,500, uh, a d, uh,
no problem.
But if you're out there in north
Umbria or anywhere for that matter in a
monastery somewhere where it's really
crucial to celebrate it on the right day.
Remember what I said about
Dogma and religious observation?
God doesn't want you to
say something like, dude,
I don't really know any Easter is,
but I think I'm going to celebrate it.
Now you can't do that.
You can't just decide.
I know it's sort of in the spring,
uh,
nobody around here for miles and miles
and miles, and it was how to calculate it.
So what the heck?
We'll do it on a Tuesday because I'm
busy out in the thumb on what I think is
east or something.
That's not the way monasticism works.
And we'll talk about that next week. The
schedule is really, really important,
but it's also difficult to figure
out and people disagree about it.
To this day,
the eastern Orthodox churches celebrate
a different date for Easter than the
western because they operate according
to a different calendar. All right, well,
so,
um,
I'm not saying that this is the kind
of knowledge that you want to drop
everything else to pursue,
but it is a kind of knowledge
that requires a sort of
observation that in fact,
we do not have, um, most of us,
unless we're astronomy majors,
have no idea what the sky
looks like at night. Uh,
a because we can't see it because of
artificial light and be because we're not
very curious.
We cannot track animals,
most of us.
And those of you who
can, uh, um, you know,
I'm interested in your knowledge.
Most of us haven't the faintest idea how
things grow except because we've been
to the Yale farm and oh my gosh,
look at this stuff. Um, you know,
that's part of the reason for it
because we're not very close to nature.
Uh, I think that environmental
concerns, not withstanding,
most of us have a huge investment
in not being too close to nature,
but the observation of
phenomena is something that
is much superior in so-called
indigenous primitive,
traditional or historical societies.
So the story of England and
Ireland centers on conversion.
And the reason this is a so is because
conversion represents a change in
orientation,
a change in orientation towards a larger
world instead of a kind of tribal and
fragmented identity.
It's not making,
I'm not making a statement about the
truth or non truth of Christianity,
but about the sense of belonging to a
larger world whose purposes encompass not
only your group,
but a larger group of people out there.
And I think we can get a feeling for
this from a famous passage of beads,
ecclesiastical history written in seven
31 and he is describing events of about
a century earlier when
King Edwin of North Umbria,
someone to council to decide whether or
not to accept the Christian God and the
chief of the Pagan priests speaks in favor
of embracing Christianity even though
you would think that he would be
the defender of the old faith.
He in fact speaks to this assembly
according to bead in favor of
Christianity on the grounds that it tells
us what went before us and what will
come after us.
And the passage goes like this and one
of the kings chief men presently said,
thus seems that to me,
Oh king,
the present life of Man on
earth against that time,
which is unknown to us is as if you were
sitting at a feast with your chief men
and your things, your nobles
in wintertime, t, h, a. N, e.
S
the fire burns and the hole is warm
and outside it rains and snows and storms.
There comes a sparrow and
swiftly flies through the house.
The insulation is not great
in these halls, right?
It comes through one door and it goes out
another low in the time in which he is
within.
He has not touched by the winter storm,
but that time is the flash of
an eye and the least of times.
And he soon passes from
winter out to winter again.
So is the life of man
revealed for a brief space,
but what went before and what
follows after? We do not know.
Therefore, if this teaching can
reveal any more certain knowledge,
it seems only right. We
should follow it. Now,
this is not why people necessarily
converted because not everybody's really
bothered by that. But most people
figure, wow, I'm in the hall.
It's warm, it's great. I'm
having such a good time.
And when I have to leave brief though,
it will be, I'll deal with that.
Uh,
but it does explain some of the appeal
of Christianity and why the invaders who
were, uh, um,
quote pagan converted and indeed why
people tend to convert to world religions
like Christianity and Islam.
To this day,
a local religion come calling tribal
only because by that I mean confined to a
people whose identity is
caught up in their religion.
A tribal people are a tribal religion
has trouble surviving extensive contact
with other people,
okay?
Because,
um,
it's uniqueness is threatened by the
realization that there's a huge world out
there of lots of other people.
And when you start interacting with them,
that is when you're no
longer isolated, uh, eh,
you will tend to seek an explanation for
things that is grander than just these
gods protect my sphere.
This God protects my hearth.
This God protects against
accidents in childbirth,
okay?
There are exceptions.
Judaism is one of the most obvious.
Here is a religion of a small group
of people that survives, uh, um,
over the centuries.
Uh,
but it is not exactly a tribal religion
in the sense that it's monotheistic and
historical sense is very strong.
And this is what the priest means.
Uh,
or at least this is what I mean,
and interpreting the priests
words as reported by bead,
by historical sense, a sense that God, uh,
rules of the world. Even if I'm not in
it, that there is something to come,
not necessarily that
there is an afterlife,
although that obviously is part
of the teachings of Christianity,
but that there is a kind
of a purpose to life.
So conversion, the conversions of, um,
Ireland and England are different.
Um,
the process of converting England begins
in five 97 with a missionary known.
Uh, unfortunately his name is
Augustine, Augustine of Canterbury,
not Augustine of hippo,
the confessions, Augustine,
he is sent by the Roman Pope Gregory the
first Gregory the great bead tells us
that he was motivated to do this.
It's a very strange thing to do.
There had not been missionaries
sent by the pope before, uh,
that he was motivated to do this by
seeing British boys for sale in the slave
market in Rome and asking who they were.
He was told they were angles.
A Anglos as an Anglo Saxon Aang les,
and he is reputed to have said, uh, uh,
we should make them angels, not
angles. Uh, [inaudible], uh,
known, uh, uh, uh,
on glee or um, uh, Angel's not ankles.
Okay.
Whatever the story.
Augustine
arrived around five 97 at an island
that had some remanence of Celtic
Christianity,
but is basically a pagan and barbarian.
He landed in Kent in the
southeast corner of the island,
closest to the continent. And on
this map, what I'd like you to know,
particularly our Kent with Canterbury as
its capital and the south east west six
in the west.
So I think I've helpfully underlined
Murcia towards the center,
North Umbria, northeast, uh,
the most important kingdoms in England.
And,
and what come has emphasized how
fragmented this territory was?
The most important kingdoms
would be at different times,
Northumbria show and west sex.
But the first place to convert is Kent.
It faces the continent.
The Pagan Ruler of Kant had actually
married a Christian princess from
Merovingian Gall and Augustine established
the first bishop Rick in Kent at
Canterbury,
which would be henceforth the major
ecclesiastical center of Britain.
It's Archbishop Prek
bead tells us about this, but he also
tells us a lot more about North Umbria,
which is where he lived.
And here you can see the off again
on again, pace of conversion.
Yeah,
the pious King Edwin who had that council
that we just described converted his
people after a vision.
But after his death and six 33,
his successor went back to
the old traditional religion,
renouncing Christianity,
and then the successor to that king,
a man named Oswald
reestablished Christianity.
But he was killed in battle by the
Pagan King of Mercer. And six 42
only in the six 66,
seven days is England pretty
definitively converted to Christianity.
We can see this kind of transition,
uh,
in,
two of the most famous sources
of information about this world.
The Poem Beowulf, how many
people have read this? Yeah,
everybody's read this
at one time or another.
Beowulf does have some little Christian
themes and there is some debate as to
what extent the poem is to be
understood in Christian terms.
But it's atmosphere.
It's rituals,
the burial and the ship, the
burning of the body, the devotion,
not only to war,
but to feasting and two gold ring giving,
uh, it evokes, not merely evokes, it is,
uh,
a description of a
warrior society in which,
although it is written in old English,
remember that it actually
takes place in Denmark.
This is a North Sea world in which the
communications patterns are such that you
could write an English poem about,
uh,
someone who goes over to
the mainland for adventure.
The other source is one of the
great archeological triumphs of,
uh, the last hundred years. The
so called Sutton who treasure,
which is in the British
Museum, uh, in East Anglia,
uh, close to the water,
actually close to the sea.
A burial ship was found in 1939 probably,
uh,
the king buried here was,
um,
uh, red Wald, king of East Anglia, um,
uh,
who died in six 27.
Now it's a pagan burial, uh, because
of all the grave goods. You know,
all this stuff is in there.
Uh, or so it would seem,
but it's hard to tell just as in
Beowulf, is it pagan? As a Christian,
it's hard to tell about this burial scene
because he's got a lot of stuff from
what might be called foreign gifts
or maybe plunder foreign gifts.
He's got two Byzantines silver spoons,
so two silver spoons made in
Constantinople or thereabouts.
He's got gold coins.
They're mostly from the
Merovingian kingdom. And they,
they're, they're different.
They're all different.
This is not an economic thing.
This is a treasure thing,
right?
The difference between economy and
treasure is that treasure is just for
hoarding and economy is
fluid and transactional.
The hoarding, of course we see in
Beowulf most obviously with the Dragon,
the dragon is not accumulating
the treasure in order to
safeguard his retirement
know or, or a trade up in caves. Um,
he just sleeps on this tracer. And
the point of that is, of course,
the people accumulate treasure
for noneconomic reasons,
uh,
for reasons that have to do with
their own satisfaction or their own,
uh,
anxieties.
And the utility of treasure
is generally overestimated.
Nevertheless, of course, at the same time,
this is a world in which gold
treasure accumulation is what men do.
Okay.
Uh, so what else is at Sutton
who a wonderful helmet,
a unique in because these,
these things tend to disintegrate a,
a sword.
Okay.
A male shirt.
Um,
and then all sorts of
little paraphernalia.
Some of it with Christian symbols
like crosses some of it very much, uh,
in the pagan kind of a, um, world.
Beowulf and Sutton who go together,
they both show us a world
of treasure of weapons,
uh,
of drinking halls of palaces,
sort of isolated.
The drinking hall is important as
you know from Beowulf. It is, uh,
the manifestation of civilization.
It is that protection from outside that
bade just be described in the little
sparrow anecdote,
but it is also the center of government.
We're back to the ruler and his
entourage or come and talk to us,
his gang,
if you want to put a more
cynical coloration on it.
So the conversion of England is
completed by the late seventh century,
but it is a more complicated story than
just monolithic Christianity versus
monolithic paganism.
Because there are two
kinds of Christianity that
seek to convert and Glen,
one from Ireland and one from Rome,
Ireland.
Let's just pause over Ireland never
part of the Roman empire as I said,
but it's also the first place outside
the Roman world to have been converted to
Christianity.
The first place in Europe,
actually the first place
period is Ethiopia.
Ethiopia of course in North Eastern
Africa would be converted to Christianity.
Uh, very early fourth
century. Hey d probably,
but within Europe, Ireland was
converted to Christianity. Um,
uh, by, um,
the British or English missionary
Saint Patrick. Um, this is,
uh, a little embarrassing,
but in fact the,
the apostle to Ireland is a
one of those British Celtic,
Roman fourth century figures,
Patrick.
So in 600 a d Ireland was
largely Catholic. Well,
England was mostly pagan.
Irish Christianity had
certain peculiarities,
some of them related to its lack
of a Roman past. Thus, for example,
it did not have bishops really,
or the bishops were weak because there
had not been cities in Ireland on the
Roman model. And therefore, Christianity
didn't have an urban background,
but rather a very decentralized
and rural background.
The most powerful institutions in Ireland
were monasteries because these were
great rural centers. And also the monks
ruled over the bishops. Generally,
Irish monasticism was very austere.
The Irish monks were more aesthetic.
Van Amongst,
we'll be meeting next week from the
Benedictine tradition started in Italy,
and they also were less
fixed in one place.
Okay?
In Benedictine Monasticism,
you're not supposed to move.
You're supposed to be stable.
You're supposed to go through
the same routine every day.
The Irish favored a more wandering
existence and the establishment of little
communities or colonies,
far away,
the Irish form of piety emphasizes exile.
And it might be exile,
too scary and almost
unimaginable kind of environment.
There are,
for example,
lots of little islands in the Irish Sea,
uh, that seem to be
uninhabitable. That is,
if you look at them from the,
the tour boat,
you see a lot of birds and you know,
it's birder's paradise. But you know,
in the middle of July it's overcast
and raining and the sea is pounding.
And then you notice the little
remanence of houses. Yup.
Uh,
question Oh,
a little caves.
Uh,
where people in the sixth and
seventh lived or the island is tiny,
you know, a smaller than this
building and there, you know,
it looks like 20 people were living there.
What are they living on?
Well, poultry I guess, but, uh, um, uh,
this is a very severe form
of a sudden as Satta system.
And the wondering also can mean just
holing up on some island or wandering
around the European con
continent and converting people.
The Irish were great missionaries
both to England and to the continent.
And we'll be talking about that
some more. What about the, um,
the Irish as the saviors of civilization?
A book published about eight,
nine years ago, uh, how the Irish saved
civilization is like all such, well,
most sucky popular books,
um,
kind of overdone and reductionist.
Um,
it's not literally exactly true,
but here again, as with England,
we have a society that had no
Roman influence and yet had a,
a highly developed tradition of learning,
preservation of Latin in part very good
knowledge of Latin because they didn't
think they spoke it. Remember we said
the PM people in the former Roman empire,
it's hard to date the point
at which someone in Spain, uh,
is no longer speaking Latin,
but it's speaking something that we
can start to call Spanish and Ireland.
The distinction was quite clear.
You had to learn Latin in lessons.
You had to go to class,
you had to be taught Latin.
And so the Latin that was taught
was bookish. Uh, but for that,
um, uh, in many respects correct.
Finally, the, uh,
Irish celebrated Easter according
to a different calendar. Um,
and so we refer to the
Irish or the Celtic church.
We mean this more decentralized church,
there's somewhat more
wandering missionary church,
uh,
a,
a church that was less hierarchical and
less organized around bishops than that
of its rival Rome.
The story of the seventh century in
England is therefore partly the story of
competition between paganism
and Christianity and flip
flopping between them and
competition between Irish Christianity
represented by, for example,
the monastery of Iona
in what's now Scotland.
I o n a a the missions of Saint Iden,
a I d a n whom bead describes with great
sympathy even though he doesn't agree
with him,
but the controversy really
centered ultimately or at least,
um,
in an immediate sense over Easter
at the Senate of in six 64.
Okay.
It was decided to embrace
the Roman calculation of
Easter and we're that bishops
hierarchy,
a more organized church.
I have a lot of trouble with
this Easter problem. I mean,
you will have noticed that I've evaded
telling you exactly what the calculations
are. Some of you may know
much better than me, but um,
the Jewish Passover is
established by lunar months.
Christians wanted to break with Jewish
tradition and celebrating east year, uh,
uh, uh, according to a
somewhat different calendar.
So it combined lunar and
solar methods of calculation,
very complex operation.
Therefore,
in a year for 55, Rome, that is to
say the papacy under our friendly,
over the first, uh,
mission to the huns, um,
definition of the two natures
of Christ. Leo The first, uh,
and Rome opted for a 19 year
cycle of calculating Easter,
but the Celtic churches cut off from
the continent. Remember, we're in this,
uh, uh, post Roman world
have very little contact,
kept an 84 year cycle.
So in the seventh century when the
Roman missionaries had arrived again,
you have two conflicting dates
for Easter every year. I mean,
occasionally just as with the Orthodox
and Catholic Easters, they come together.
So every so often I will
actually be the same Sunday,
but generally speaking different.
And so you get these
ludicrous scenes like king us,
we have North Umbria celebrating Easter
according to the Celtic tradition.
And his wife who was from Kent celebrated
according to the Roman tradition.
So one Sunday was Celtic Easter and
then the next Sunday was Roman eastern.
Okay.
So it's not so much that Easter
is so important intrinsically,
but it is a symbol of the
embrace of the Roman, uh,
form of Christianity and the bringing
of England into an orientation more
towards the continent.
Then towards the Celtic West.
What is amazing, as I said before, is how
quickly once the conversion takes place,
England becomes not only integrated
into the continent, but a place of, uh,
a great cultural accomplishment.
The Great Archbishop of Canterbury
of this post with B era Theodore,
archbishop of Canterbury,
six 69 to six 90 established bishoprics
monasteries
and endowed them with books.
Theodore is an interesting character.
He's actually from Syria.
Okay.
And how somebody from Syria
becomes Archbishop of Canterbury,
something that would be very
unlikely now in the seventh century,
a d a is an aspect of some preservation
of the outlines of the cosmopolitan
Roman world that we began the course web.
There are a lot of Syrian
pope's at this time,
two Syrian and Greek popes
from the eastern Mediterranean.
The
first manuscript we have of the
Bible as a single manuscript.
In other words,
we're,
all of the books of the Bible are
contained in the same volume is from this
place and this era, the so
called Codex Amiya, Tina's,
okay.
A magnificently decorated by ball.
Okay.
Sent to the pope in seven
16 written at beads,
monastery of Gero.
Now in Florence at the metallurgy
Lorencia and library of Florence.
Yeah,
it is decorated in this very distinctive
style, but you all know of if not,
uh, um, from courses from
Christmas cards and stuff.
The book of Kells is the
most famous example of this.
This is the so called enchilada style
because it's shared by both Celtic Ireland
and Anglo Saxon England.
Lots of intricate curlicues,
complicated animals,
a magnificent contracts of color,
a kind of abstraction.
When you first look at it,
it looks like an oriental carpet,
but in fact,
if you look at it a little more closely,
you can see that there are all sorts
of little intertwining, uh, animals,
uh, or, uh,
fantastic shapes and colors within it.
Questions,
problems.
We could spend an entire semester
on, uh, England. But, uh,
I think we've had at least a
taste of it's significance,
both in its own right and as one more
and rather different aspect of the post
Roman world that we've been occupied with.
I'll see you for the exam on Monday.